what i want to introduce to you is just
one of the many vehicles that exist to
incentivize employees
and it's called phantom equity so i was
having a conversation with a newer
business owner and he was talking about
how
he had this person who was good at
marketing and he wanted to give them a
percentage of his business but not the
whole business
in order to do his marketing and after
talking about it a little bit more it
became clear that
it really should just have a performance
relationship and not give up equity
but one of the key things is that there
are positions that are more difficult to
measure within a business that it does
make sense over time to
you know give some sort of equity to an
employee because i have realized over
time is that in order to
grow my slice of the pie it's better to
get a bigger pie and have more people
get wealthy and so having other people
use
my business as a vehicle for their
wealth has ultimately allowed me to gain
leverage on how i can
increase my own wealth and one of my
rules of life is the more money i make
other people the more money i make
and that is not just limited to your
customers it's also applies to your
employees and that's been something that
it took me much longer than i
expected much longer than i had hoped to
learn so hopefully i can transfer that
lesson to you faster
sam walton even talked about this in his
book made in america
how he said one of the biggest things
that influenced walmart's growth is when
they created their employee stock option
program
and by doing that he said there was such
a tremendous amount of buy-in
that the company just continued to roar
and grow and he said he wished he had
done it sooner and so
taking the advice from that man and
somebody who's made much less money than
sam walton
myself what i want to introduce to you
is just one of the many vehicles that
exist to incentivize employees
and it's called phantom equity this is
something that i have used in
every company that i own uh believe it
or not i've used phantom equity
to incentivize high level employees in
just about every company and
it happened because i actually had
someone use it with me
as an affiliate so i was an affiliate of
a big software company and the ceo flew
out and was like hey how can i make this
really worth it for you to like push
this
and i was like listen man like i i enjoy
the you know affiliate commissions uh
but i for me to really make this like a
focus
i would need some sort of equity on the
upside he said well what if i instead of
giving you equity
um i can give you phantom equity and i
was like what's that and so he explained
it and i want to explain
you know to the extent that i understand
it as an entrepreneur explain it to you
as we've used it so
i'm going to break this down to the
employee and the owner all right
now in this case the example i just said
i wasn't an employee but i i still have
treatment i'll use the employee as the
example here all right
so there's a couple different variables
that you can think through about phantom
equity so fandom equity is simply put
equity that is not vested but has events
that can trigger its vesting
vesting means whether it's it's happened
or not like
does that equity exist it is it yours or
not has it vested
all right so the first thing is famine
equity is typically triggered upon a
sale or a change in liquidity
now there's variables all of this stuff
is negotiable all of these things have
variables so
i could say for example the phantom
equity vests or you are able to
participate in a transaction of the
company if
ownership changes if majority ownership
changes so that would be a clause that i
could say if i sell a majority of the
company then you can liquidate your
shells
along with me now the reason that you
might not include something like that is
because a buyer might not want the
key employees to leave with the
liquidation event so that's something
that would protect the owner
now if you wanted to say hey i want to
do it so that you guys can participate
then you could also put like you can
sell up to this amount or you can sell a
proportional amount so there's lots of
different caveats here but big picture
most people have the phantom equity so
that if there is a transaction of some
sort
the employees can also participate in it
and build their own wealth alongside
the objective of phantom equity is to
get owner-like
thinking and owner-like engagement
owner-like behavior among people who are
not majority owners of the business
and a lot of times this makes a ton of
sense like i used to be so stingy with
equity early on
well in the very beginning i was really
really loose with equity and then i kind
of like
swung back the other direction didn't
want to give anyone equity and i feel
like now i've kind of
fallen in the middle path of i don't
need to give huge chunks away to people
i need to find people who are key
key players and give them phantom equity
that is proportional the effort and the
contribution that they have
right i used to give away
disproportionate chunks and i ended up
paying for it
and then later i ended up trying to find
ways to incentivize hot
incentivize and attract high level
employees and the best people want a
stake because
winners win and they want they know
they're going to win so they want to
have be able to participate in the
upside so
number one uh that is where sale is
triggered the second
is that it's beneficial from a wealth
standpoint because the employee can
increase the value of
their wealth their stake their phantom
equity by increasing the value of the
business
right and the beauty of that is that
it's entirely tax free now the owner and
employer completely aligned on this one
together
now from a tax standpoint the reason you
do fandom equity instead of normal
equity is that if you give normal equity
the employee also gets the downside of
equity all right so
this is good for the employee right it's
good because the employee doesn't have
to buy the equity because normally if
you actually have an equity transfer a
true transfer
then what happens they actually have to
pay tax on it because they're getting
something right i can't just
zuckerberg can't just give you know all
of your shares to facebook to somebody
they have to pay taxes on it right
and so you can't that is a taxable event
when you transfer equity so you make it
phantom equity because it doesn't
technically invest
unless a trigger occurs and so what that
does is it means that they don't have to
get taxed on it right which is
beneficial you know for the employee
right now the downside of this though is
that typically it will get triggered as
regular income
during the sale now there's ways of
writing this i'm not going to get into
the complexities around this
but this is kind of around the vesting
schedule which is when are they going to
get this so for example you could say i
want to give you
five percent of this company and i want
to give it to you over five years which
means you get one percent a year for the
next five
years and you could say hey i want to
create a cliff which means that
after the first year the entire first
percent vest then after that every
quarter
another point two five percent fest
after that so that means that at you
know month
nine they're still zero investing and
then at month you know
13 they'll have one percent that will
have vested in its entirety and then
after that it's it's piecemeal
right what happens if the employee
leaves now one of the benefits to this
and this protects the owner is what if
you say
you know someone comes in they're a hot
shot they're you know smooth talking and
they're like yeah man i want to
phantom equity whatever and they and
you're like sure i'm going to give you
five percent over the next five years
right and let's say they
they leave within you know x period of
time now
a upon the termination of the employee
you can have them
not get those um and you can also write
that into the original green which means
that if you leave you
lose your phantom equity right which
also gets people to stick with it over
the longer term
which is why companies employ the
structure it's to incentivize people to
stay
and continue to grow the business right
this protects the
uh owner the tax thing it protects the
employee the other piece that protects
the employees that with phantom equity
they're not liable right so if something
happens in the business the employees
are personally liable which is why this
is a nice
attractive thing for many people now
this one is is something that's
interesting i want to talk about which
is profit right because a lot of times
people conflate equity with profit
you can be an equity owner and not
participate in profit distributions
you can also participate in profit
distributions and not be an equity owner
so these things are not
connected oftentimes we think of them
together because we as owners have both
but it doesn't mean that our employees
need that necessarily and i'm not saying
you shouldn't do that i'm just saying
it is yet another variable that is
considered in the negotiation
and so when i'm thinking through phantom
equity most times it's going to depend
on the value of the business
but what i learned from the you know the
mentors that i have spoken with
typically when you're having a
leadership type position
who's a senior leadership so somebody
who's like on the executive track
they might get between half a percent to
two percent depending again on
the value of the business their
seniority their experience etc
and if you have a true executive that's
a huge value add that is
leading you know almost half the company
etc then that is where you know
sometimes three percent four percent
five percent
um can can come into play and so
this is phantom equity there are lots of
different types of you know you can do
bonus programs you can do esops which is
a story
employee stock ownership programs
there's lots of different things you can
do in a business but this is one that i
have used and has been very very
helpful for me i've had people leave who
had had equity
and we've been able to be on good terms
everything's been fine
they were protected from a tax
standpoint i tend to
keep profit sharing not to say that it's
bad or a good thing it's just my
preference
i love the fact that my employees can
grow their well alongside me because
they hear
the same videos that you guys watch and
then finally it's nice because
they think in terms of a sale so they're
thinking in terms of enterprise value so
the more aligned i commit mike make my
team and their life outcomes with my
personal life outcomes then the more
aligned will be and ultimately
the faster we'll move in that direction
because we're not you know pushing
focus and effort in opposite directions
we're all 100 aligned
and so phantom equity is one of the best
vehicles for that i hope you found value
in this video you can click subscribe
and
if you're thinking about doing something
like this um i'd recommend it i think
that it's better to
increase the size of the pie give a
handful of slices out to people
um who who've helped you along the way
and i think that for me
as i've shifted i really just want
everyone to be wealthy
heck there's a lot of people who are
broke and the reason i made this channel
is so that you're not one of them one of
the best
things that i can think of is helping
the people who've helped me build this
and so
building my employees wealth is
something that is my is something top of
mind for me and trying to find new ways
and creative ways to build wealth
without necessarily sacrificing
you know we've built and risked to get
here so hope you found it valuable click
subscribe and i'll see you guys next
week
bye